Andy as I seem to recall,
you're a pretty big trivia
guy, isn't that right?
I am pretty good at trivia I gotta say.
[Conan] Oh, you think you're pretty good?
[Andy] I do, Yeah.
[Conan] Well, I too think
I'm pretty good at trivia.
So I thought maybe we'd
have a friendly little
trivia competition on tonight's show.
There's nothing friendly
about trivia Conan.
I know Andy.
I know we're both pretty
competitive about this.
It is on, let's do it right now.
(electricity buzzing)
Alright, here we go, you ready?
[Andy] I was born ready O'Brien.
Alright, which planet is the fourth,
furthest from the sun?
Mars,
Correct, your turn Andy.
[Andy] Alright, here we go.
In feudal Japan, Samurai roamed the land,
living by an honor code
called the Bushido.
What is the sixth virtue of the Bushido?
What, what are you talking about?
That's so complicated.
How am I supposed to know that?
The answer is honor Conan,
I knew you wouldn't get it.
[Conan] No no no, that's not fair.
Give me a simpler question.
[Andy] Oh, okay sure, French
philosopher Rene Descartes,
is well known for his work on metaphysics.
What object in many
displays throughout Paris.
First ignited Descartes'
philosophies on dualism?
Andy come on, it's called trivia
because it's supposed to be trivial.
Stop giving me complicated questions.
Alright fine, here's a simple one.
What's AT&T 5G ?
Easy, why It's 5G that's
fast, reliable and secure.
[Andy] That's right Conan,
t's not complicated.
[Conan] Alright, here's one for you, Andy.
Which 5G is fast, reliable and secure?
[Andy] Well AT&T 5G of course.
[Conan] That's right Andy,
it's not complicated.
(both laughing)